you guys look like what I expect Boston
to look like is this a family outing
this is really cute
why are you saying no dude that's
disrespectful of the year is this your
mom oh that's up that's why he
was saying it's not family that was
childish of you he was like that's my
stepmom that's not my family
how old are you 32 you can't have those
little white teenage angst brother even
Eminem is let go of his anger hangs hold
on a cute double date why can't that be
a beautiful double day you guys and this
is your stepmom so you can be like Dad
you beating it up or what it's not weird
it's not an inappropriate thing it's not
weird in any way shape or form what do
you do for a living sir
oh that's amazing that's like
almost military let me ask you a
question when you're taking a flight
like all active military are you like
that's me because I think that's that's
taking advantage you know I mean that's
like you sprained your ink and you go to
the handicap spot